>> Hey, everyone, my name is
Andrew Gasparovic.  I  am an
engineer at Google research
working on machine  intelligence
.  And today, I'm excited to
give you an  introduction in
machine learning using
TensorFlow.  I'll  show you some
examples of how we've been
using it at  Google.  And I'll
share with you a few recent and
up  coming developments and then
talk about how you can get
started solving real problems
with machine learning.  So
first, let's talk about exactly
what it is that  TensorFlow does
and why you might want to use
it.   TensorFlow lets you get
straight to work solving all
kinds of machine learning tasks.
The goal is that in  general,
no matter what your problem
looks like,  TensorFlow should
be able to support it at some
level of  the API.  And in
general, it's designed to be
fast, so  it's optimized for the
hardware and the platforms that
you actually want to use it
with.  One of the things  that I
think really makes it unique in
terms of machine  learning
frameworks
is that you can actually build
a  model in let's say five or
ten lines of code and then  take
that model and scale it all the
way up to  production.  So you
can train that model on the
cluster  of tens or even
hundreds of machines, and then
take that  model and serve it
using super low
latentcy predictions.
So let's talk about what it is
when I say model  and how
machine learning relates to that
.
Here's a simple problem.
Predict whether an image
contains a cat or a dog.  This
is something that would  be
difficult or even impossible to
do with traditional  programming
because how do you make a set
of rules of  what is a cat
versus what is a dog?  And then
on top of  that capture all the
variations like breeds, poses,
the  brightness and scaling of
the image, all of that kind of
thing.  So what we can do
instead is make a neuronetwork
neuronetwork, which is an
extremely simplified version  of
how neurons in the brain work.
Each one of the dots  in this
image is a neuron, and they're
all connected  together layer by
layer from the input of what we
see to  the output of what we
understand.  And then what we do
is we go through lots and lots
of examples of cat and  dog
images.  They're all labeled
with the correct  category, and
we try to make a prediction.
Initially,  all of those neurons
are just randomly initializeed,
so  it's a complete guess.
What we do is we calculate how
far we are from the guess to
the correct answer, the  error,
and then we use that error to
adjust the strength  of the
connections between the neurons.
And basically,  we want to
slowly move towards the right
answer.
After we repeat that, you know,
a million or so  times, let's
say say, then what you end up
with is a nice  cat and dog
prediction model.  But what you
actually  want to do is, you
know, build a cat and dog
prediction  website; right?  A
user gives you a photo, and you
have  to tell them whether
there's a cat or a dog in it.
And  the connection strengths
that you learn during training
are what allows your model now
to generalize.  So if you  give
it this photo, even though it
has never seen it  before, and
there's no label attached to it,
it can get  a dog prediction
out, based on what the model
learned  via those weights
attached to the neuron about,
you know know, the nature of
cats versus dogs.  At least in
terms  of the images that it is
seeing.
But how much it can actually
learn is a function  of the
model, size, and complexity.
And we just didn't  have
computer power and the tools to
experiment with  really big and
complicated models, until very
recently.   This picture is
basically what neural networks
used to  look like maybe five or
ten years ago.  And at that
point, they had a small number
of neurons, they were  just
fully connected between the
layers, if there were  that many
layers, and then the end result
is they  weren't super powerful
.  In fact, for a problem like
computer vision, they were
almost written off compared  to
a specializeed hand-tuned model
that was built by  experts for
that exact task.
And you can compare that to a
neural network model  that we
use today for image
classification, this is  called
inception, and the idea is that
you feed in an  image, and you
get a prediction of what's in
the image,  among thousands of
categories.  I think it's, like,
17,000 potential classes.
And with a framework like
TensorFlow, you can  train a
model like this that has, you
know, tons of  layers and is
much more complicated than the
early  networks.  That's what we
mean when we say deep learning
learning.  The deep in this case
refers to a deeper  arrangement
of layers and the more
complicated  connections that
comes with that.
The end result is that you have
millions or even  billions of
neurons in your model.  And
that's what  allows a deep
neural network to get results
that can  actually vastly out
perform the earlier hand built,
hand  tuned hand- hand-tuned
models.
But the specific reason why
TensorFlow is so  efficient in
working with those huge networks
is because  it turns the code
that you write into a graph of
operations.  And it's the graph
that it actually runs.   The
data, by the way, that flows
between those  operations are
called tensors, which is where
the name  comes from.  And
because your model's represented
as a  graph, you can do things
like delaying or removing un
unnecessary operations, or even
reusing partial results.   The
other thing that you can do
really easily is the  process
called back propagation.  So if
you remember  when we updated
the strength of connections in
our model  based on the examples
that we saw and the error that
we  calculated, that's the
process of back propagation.
Because the model's represented
as a graph of operations
instead of code, you don't have
to write additional code  for
that, you can just compute and
apply those updates
automatically.
And another nice side effect of
having a wrap  around is that
you can in your code using a
one-line  decoration, I want
this part of the graph to run
over  here, I want this part of
the graph to be distributed to
a different set of machines.  Or
you can even say I want  this
part of the graph that's very
math intensive to run  on a GPU
while the data input code runs
back on the CPU.
And TensorFlow runs on CPUs and
GPUs out of the  box.  It also
can load models and run
inference tasks  like doing a
prediction or a classification
on iOS and  Android devices.
And now even raspberry pi device
.  And  inside of our data
centers, we've been serving
TensorFlow graphs using the
specially
hardware called TP TPU.  And
then going forward in the
network, the strains  of
connections between the neurons
for each layer.  That  is
basically very large matrix math
operations, and  that's
something that TPUs do a lot of
very quickly very  well.
Version two of the TPU hardware
we're calling the  cloud TPU,
and I will talk a little bit
more about that  in a bit.
So once upon a time, Python was
basically the only  choice if
you wanted to build a TensorFlow
graph.  And  it's still a
perfectly great choice.  It's
very simple.   There's a lot of
example code out there.  It
supports  everything out of the
box.  But there's also support
for  a whole variety of other
languages.  And since
TensorFlow is open source, there
are a lot more  additional
language choices with community
support that  are being added
all the time.
And so the end result is that
if you're interested
interested, you can try out
TensorFlow in probably your
favorite language right now, and
it will work out of the  box.
And I just wanted to mention, my
coworkers on the  TensorFlow
serving team just announced
their 1.0 release  last month,
which is a really huge milestone
for them  because TensorFlow
serving is a very, very high
performance piece of
infrastructure that you can use
to  load your models and then
serve inference requests, low
latentcy on your servers.
Internally, we use it for about
800 products, but  we really
wanted to release it as part of
the open  source distribution
because it's such an important
aspect of, you know, a real
world deployment.  That's  one
of the things that when we say
TensorFlow is  production ready,
it's things like this that
makes the  difference between
code that you write for doing
research and being able to
actually run it in production
solving real problems.
Another one is a tool called
Tensor Board.  So  this is one
of the visualizeers included in
the package.   This particular
one is showing a clustering of
hand- hand-written digits that a
model learned for that
particular task.
In general, visualizing what's
happening in a  particular model
and then trying to debug
predictions  that you get out of
it has traditionally been a
very  difficult aspect of
machine learning.  It's kind of,
you  know, one of the achilles
heels of a lot of machine
learning frameworks.
So that's something that we
really  wanted to include
because that -- you wouldn't be
able  to serve something in
production unless you were
actually able to understand
what's going on inside of  the
model and figure out if the
prediction that doesn't  match
what you expected, why that's
happening.
So that production readyiness in
general has been  one of the
keys to the success of the
framework and one  of the things
that makes it different.
TensorFlow since  its release,
has been the number one machine
learning  repository on GitHub.
And it's really been incredible
to see the adoption since it
was released.  This chart  shows
the number of stars on GitHub
since it was  launched.  And
last time I checked, it was I
think over,  like, 68,000 at
this point.
And I think one of the other
reasons is because we  actually
take our place in the open
source community  really
seriously, it's never been for
us a matter of,  you know,
throwing code over the wall or
taking a thump  from our source
code repository and just open
sourcing  data, and that's the
end of it.  Open source and open
source contributors have been
totally a first-class a first-
class part  of the process since
it was released.  At this point
,  we've had more than 1,000
external contributors on
TensorFlow, and some of those
external commits have  added
huge new features like
additional language that  was
mentioned earlier.  Additional
hardware support, and  even
whole new platforms that
TensorFlow runs on.
And the other aspect of our open
source work is  making sure
that users are productive and
informed about  how best to use
TensorFlow, so to do that, we've
answered thousands of
questions on Stack Overflow, and
we are also very serious about
looking into fixing  issues on
our GitHub issues page.  Because
in general,  we want to have a
really seamless experience from
the  time that you download the
framework to the time that  you
actually launch a model in
production.
But just to be clear, you know,
we use TensorFlow  a lot within
Google.  This graph shows the
number of  directories in our
source control tree with models
in  them over time.  And the
orange bar is when we
internally release TensorFlow
for all projects to use.   So
you can see before that, there
was interest to  machine
learning and some people white
listed or using  our precursor
framework.  And then after it
was released released, it just
exploded, and there are more
than  6,000 products at Google
using TensorFlow today.  And,
in fact, it's pretty much every
major Google product is  using
TensorFlow and doing machine
learning in some form  or
another.  And that has given us
a ton of feedback and
opportunities to make TensorFlow
better by doing things  like
streamlining the APIs that we
provide, adding new  high level
APIs over time to make it easier
to use, and,  you know, also,
just providing some of the
production- production-ready
tools that I mentioned.
So let me show you some of the
things that we've  been
specifically using TensorFlow
for because there's  so much
variety in the types of problems
, it's I think a  good
demonstration of how flexible it
is as a framework.   Google
translate used to use a model
that basically  translated word
by word.  Maybe a few phrases
here and  there, but that was
basically the extent of it.  And
then on top of that, it had
hundreds and thousands of  lines
of hand-tuned code written with
the input of  linguists and
language experts.  Even so, it
had a lot  of difficulty
accommodating all the nuances
and  differences in languages.
So here's an example on the
right of it  translating a
particular Chinese phrase into
where will  the restroom, which,
you know, leaves a lot of room
for  improvement.  We've
replaced that entire previous
system  with a new deep neural
network-based system called
neural machine translation, and
that's running on  TensorFlow.
And the end result is that many
of the  language pairs have had
huge gains in translation
quality, up to 85% in some cases
.  And the reason why is
because the model works by
considering a whole sequence  of
words.  A sequence input and a
sequence output.  So  the end
result is that you get a more
natural-sounding  output, much
more like a human translator
would do.  For  instance, here,
excuse me, where is the toilet?
A much  better result.
And sticking with that
translation theme, we added  the
word lens feature to the app,
and this is actually  running on
the mobile device.  It works in
airplane mode mode, which is
pretty incredible, considering
that it's  doing basically a
combination of computer vision
and  translation all in the same
model.  We had to add  features
to TensorFlow specifically to
make things like  that possible.
And now, you can train a model
on a  cluster of servers on one
machine, however you would do
it normally, but then take that
model and reduce the  size of it
to fit on the device while
keeping the  quality high.
And then Google photos is an
example of an already  great
product that was enhanced by
adding machine  learning
functionality to it.  So in
about six months  time, the team
took that image-based
classification  system and got
it working live in Google photos
.  And  the idea is that you can
take a term and search for it
in your photos for pretty much
anything.  Like, you can  type
in beach and get photos of
beaches, you can type in  photo
and get an image that contains
umbrella in it or  even an
abstract term like sunny without
previously  having added those
tags to your photos.
A more difficult image-based
task using another  deep neural
network is the show and tell
model from  Google Research.
It takes an image input, and it
outputs a human- human-sounding
caption.  It also starts with
that  inception model, but in
this case, it's not just
classifying the objects that
appear in the image, it's
actually writing a caption that
sounds natural and  captures the
relationship between objects
that appear in  the image.
To do that, the model was fine-
tuned on examples  of images
that had human-generated
captions.  And from  that, it
learned about relationships.  As
a side effect  of that process,
the model actually got better
at  describing details in the
images like colors because it
found that those are things that
humans want to hear in  a
caption that they like.
So Google Research, by the way,
open sourced the  entire model,
and there's an in-depth post
about it on  the research blog,
and you can go there and follow
the  links and try it out for
yourself.
One of the other things that
we've been doing at  Google
research is working on diagnose
ing a condition  called diabetic
retinopathy using computer
vision.   Ideally photo and
ophthalmologists, they take an
image  like this and analyze it
for early signs of diabetic
neuropathy.  The problem is
there aren't enough open  that
ophthalmologists going around,
and the end result it is  the
leading cause of blindness in
the world.
So we published an article in
the Journal of the  American
Medical Association, which shows
that a  computer vision model
can actually be as good or even
slightly better than the
average ophthalmologists at
diagnoseing the condition.  So
that's something we're  really
excited about.  Because if we
can get the model  out there,
then it will have a real impact
to help find  more of these
cases Brits before it's too late
.
And one last thing from the
research team is this  problem
using a deep neural network to
actually learn  what kind of
architectures are good for
solving  different types of
problems.
So what we're able to do is do a
search from a  poor-performing
machine-learning model to one
that's  much more accurate
without any human intervention
in  between.  The model actually
builds a machine-learning
model that solves the task.  And
those sort of problems  are
called learnings learn, which is
a really exciting  area in the
field of research, and there's
going to be a  lot more
happening in the next couple of
years in that  area.
But just before you get the idea
that, you know,  TensorFlow is
meant for long-term research or
meant for  big budget
blockbuster apps, I wanted to
show you a  Japanese cucumber
farmer.  His son in the back of
the  photo there built an
automatic cucumber sorter using
TensorFlow, along with an
Arduino controller and a
raspberry  raspberry pi.  He
trained the model by showing it
7,000  examples of cucumbers in
nine different categories.  And
so this is a job that his mom
was doing for ten hours at  a
time after every cucumber
harvest.  And in his words,  he
said I wanted to leave sorting
to AI so that we can  focus more
on growing good cucumbers.  So
after the  model was trained, he
hooked it up -- he hooked up a
conveyor belt to the controller
, and an array of webcams  to
the raspberry pi.  So as each
cucumber comes by the  belt,
it's imaged by the webcam, it's
classified, and  it's sorted
automatically, which I think is
just a  fantastic example of
something really outside the box
that
you can do practically with
machine learning.
And so TensorFlow was I think
really powerful for  solving all
of those sort of problems as of
the 1.0  release.  But there
have been quite a few new
developments since then.  So let
me just go over a  couple of
those with you now.
First of all, it has gotten a
lot easier to use.   So I
mention TensorFlow has always
been extremely  flexible with
the goal of being able to solve
any sort  of problem that you
throw at it.  But it wasn't
always  the easiest to use,
necessarily.  It has the
distributed  execution engine at
the bottom there, which is what
actually executes the graph of
operations and  distributes
them among the processors and
machines.   That has pretty much
stayed the same.  As of 1.0,
then  we added a layers API with
the idea that you could
construct a model without having
to actually mess around  with
the graph and operations
directly.  But you still  had to
build the actual network
architecture and all of  the
layers and that sort of thing.
Still had to do that  part by
hand.  And then we added on top
of that the  estimator API,
which is a high level way to
take a model  and combine that
with input and do the training
and  evaluation process.  Now as
of 1.3, we added another  layer
on top of that
for what we call the canned
estimator.  You can create a
deep neural network  classifyier
in literally one line of code.
And then when  you use the high
level estimator APIs, you get a
bunch  of things for free like
distributed training, automatic
snapshots, and the ability to
run on a mix of hardware  that
you have like the CPUs Us and GP
Us.  You also get all  of the
best guarantees that the
performance improvements  that
we've been making will actually
apply to your model model.
We've started publishing
benchmarks of different  tasks
running on different
combinations of hardware.   And
that is important because it's
going to show how  we're going
to continue to improve
performance over time time.  But
it's also important because it
can tell you  how you should
expect TensorFlow to behave on
the  combination of, you know,
hardware that you have and the
problem that you're trying to
solve.  And as far as un
uncommon configurations, here's
the cloud TPU that I was
talking about earlier.
It's the second generation
tensor processing unit.  The
first generation we only  used
for accelerating the inference
part of machine  learning.  The
second generation also
accelerates  training.  And it's
a big improvement in general
because  each cloud TPU does 180
teraflops individually.  But
they're meant to be connected,
64 of them at a time into  these
TPU pods.  One pod is 11.5
petaflops, which is an  enormous
amount of operations.  And the
neural  translation that I
talked about earlier used to
take a  full day to train on 32
of the best GPUs that we could
get our hands on.  And now we
train it to the same  accuracy
in about half a day using
one-eighth of one of  these TPU
pods.  And the -- oh,.
[Applause]
The cloud TPU, by the way, we're
making available  on the cloud
platform to external users later
on in the  year, and I'll have
a little bit more information
about  that at the end of the
talk.
We also need to make sure that
we're fully taking  advantage of
whatever hardware you give to
the machine  learning task,
whether it is a TPU or the GPUs
that you  have, or even just the
instructions that your CPU
supports.  So we've been working
on a compiler that  converts
those graphs that I talked about
directly into  assembly code.
It's called XLA, which is for
accelerated linear algebra.
It's a requirement for  running
on the TPUs, but it also runs in
Gitmo to  compile a graph for
CPUs and GPUs so that it can
choose  exactly the right
colonels for the hardware that
you  have available.  And then
there's a third mode that's
meant for mobile where you can
compile a model ahead of  time
and run predictions on the
mobile device.
The advantages that the compiled
model is much  smaller, but it
still has the possibility of
running  more efficiently as
well on the specific device.
And  one last note about mobile
is we are working on  TensorFlow
Lite, which is a whole new run
time that's  specifically built
for Android mobile devices.  The
idea  is that you put a very
slim engine in a mobile app,
which supports exactly the
hardware that you have on the
device.  And then it leaves out
all of the unnecessary  purpose
code.  When you combine that
with an XLA  compiled model, you
get the efficient use of
hardware  with a small memory
footprint.  And so you can do
this  on-device inference tasks
like I showed earlier, as well
as something new that we're
calling learning where you  can
take advantage of a model that
has been trained and  running in
the cloud somewhere, while
having your own  individual
training data on the device.
So it's never sent to the cloud,
but you can  combine those
together on the device.
Even if you have a lot of
programming experience,  I will
readyily admit that getting into
machine learning  can be
daunting.  Very daunting.  And
one of the  benefits of trying
out TensorFlow is that the stuff
you  play around with, you can
eventually actually use in
production.  But still, I would
like to give you some  tips on
how you can get started, no
matter what level  you're at.
First recommendation is to start
at TensorFlow.org  because
there's a getting started
section there that has  a nice
hands on direction to TensorFlow
, as well as some  machine-
learning tasks that you would
want to do with it it.  And they
assume some knowledge of Python
for those  particular intros,
but that's about it.
And then if you start with those
, you can progress  all the way
through the tutorials to
building things  like a
convolutional network, which is
good for image  classification,
and a recurrent network, which
is good  for those language and
translation tasks.
And then there's also a really
interesting demo of  different
neural network architectures and
parameters at  play ground.
tensorflow.org.  You can try the
different  layers through the
neurons and the learning rate
and get  an intuition about how
neural networks work by seeing
the effect on a very simple
classification problem.
And then once you start -- once
you're ready to  start building
real models to use in production
, I  recommend using that high-
level estimator and a canned
estimator APIs because you get
all of those automatic  benefits
like the save checkpoints,
exporting the tensor  board, and
the ability to do additional
training with  pretty much no
additional work.  So nine times
out of  ten or even more than
that at this point, the
estimators  and the canned
estimators are the way to go.
And then, of course, by using
estimators, you  could if you
wanted to, move your model onto
cloud TPUs  down the road pretty
much automatically.  And at G.
co/GP G.co/GPU sign up, there's
a sign up form if you're
interested in finding out more
information about those.   That
link is also the place to go to
find out about the  TensorFlow
research cloud.  So we're making
1,000 of  those cloud TPUs
available for free to machine-
learning  researchers because
there are so many people that
have  great ideas but limited
access to the kind of hardware
to do the really
state-of-the-art research.
So check out that link as well
if you would like  to apply for
that.
And finally, there are a number
of good online  courses for
machine learning.  I recommend
checking out  the Google
developers YouTube channel.  And
also, we  would ask to use deep
learning TensorFlow, which
really  gets into the deep math
background of machine learning.
And if you like that course,
it's a step closer to  getting
the machine learning nanodegree.
I hope that you want to continue
with machine  learning because
it is an incrediblely-exciting
field.   It's more accessible
than ever, and there is so much
happening.  I want to thank you
for your time, and I  hope you
enjoy the rest of your
conference.
If you are interested in giving
feedback,
you'll  have to look elsewhere.
But thanks.
[Applause]
>> Hello, everybody,. It's
great to see you here.   My name
is Alexey Kokin, and I'm on the
Google  development team.  We
work with developers across the
globe to help them grow on
Android platform.  If you  have
been following our blogs
announcement this year,  you
probably notice two important
messages that we gave.   One in
Q1, and second a few months ago.
But we are  going to move away
from just installs and
mute mutateers, and  we will
start focusing on more complex
like engagement  or box.
Today we're going to talk about
in detail, first  of all, why
it's important to have a quality
app and  we'll talk about new
tools we have to help you
troubleshoot applications and in
the end, we will  discuss how
you can benefit from having
quality app and  what can Google
Play give investing out of time
on  building applications.
First of all, let's start with
the basics.  Why it  is
important to have quality
application.
There are a lot of components
for the quality of  applications
inside Google Play, and we'll
talk in more  detail about each
and every one of the components
today.
One of the examples of
applications in Play and
performance, we have seen the
application moves on  average
quality, they display an amazing
and some of the  most important
methods for application
developers.  For  example, they
have seen up to seven times
increased  retention and up to
six times lead in spend
applications applications.
Those methods alone can make or
break  your entire application
business.  So this is phenomenal
phenomenal, and this is one of
the most crucial things  we can
focus on in building your mobile
application.
Our partners work on data
devices, they generally  confirm
oire ideas about the
applications.  Some examples
from them are examples of
significant user ratings after
performance problems of the
applications.  Have a high  rate
of
4.1, and they manage to do it
to 4.5, and those  are great
results.  Those who work on
applications, you  know how
difficult to grow when it's
already high.
Another partner, Lambda, they
have focused on  performance.
And faster launch makes a lot of
impact on  their business
critical.  As long as they gain
a lot of  graphic, in fact, on
the monitoring on the LTV.
A lot of great applications can
use and more to  use important
goods through such applications.
And finally, there's the most
important factor for  your
application in Google Play.
Every user knows every
generating helps you more five
star generating helps.   And the
statistics likes it.  50% of
negative reviews as  I mentioned
stability and bugs.  And 60% of
positive  reviews mention stuff
like speed, design, and
performance.  You know
Android Vitals is our new step
to help you build  applications,
which we announced this
May.  This is by  Google to
improve stability and
performance.  And you as  a
application developer are the
important part of this  effort.
We are starting by focusing on
three main  performance.  The
stability and rendering.  By
collecting data from devices all
over the world,.
To give you a little bit more
inside of how  different from
other and what areas you should
focus on  to improve your
application quality.
Again, support us in this
activity, and if you are
speaking about application
stability or on the  performance
on device here, even the
biggest display of  market can
benefit to doing actual good
work or  decreasing this.  For
example, Kabam
growing retention  of improving
application performance.  And
everybody in  this room knows
how important this metric is for
your  application.
So our three main areas.  First
area is stability.   Where we
focus on crashes and the
application is not  responding
when the application is frozen
for five  seconds or so.  Second
, major focal point is battery
because the main concern here is
not to overly use the  battery
of your device.
And the third focused area is
rendering because of  the way
everything is rendered faster
moved at 60 frames  per second.
And a lot of things if your UI
is slow,  from using the device
application.
So this three major areas, we
have added a new  sections play
vitals.  And so so if there is
one thing  after the
presentation, the developer
console and check  this section
for some new insights.  I will
consider my  mission a success.
And if you will analyze some of
the  data, this area and
performance improvements based
on  the statistics available.
And the best thing about Vitals
is that they  already work.  You
don't have to implement new,
you  don't have to do anything
because those statistics are
available for you right now for
your -- for each and  every
application.  And from this
users who can focus in  on the
decorations.  So if you want to
help, you should  also this
option on your device too.  It
will help you.
So let's go to the stability
areas, and I probably  will not
be focusing a lot because each
and every review review, you
definitely, you try to fix them.
But which  we call the
application not responding and
happen when  the application is
not responding.
So definitely users experience
embarked user  behaviors.  And
the issue cannot use.  But we
can  because the response
and this information in Android
Vitals.  You can head over to
the section of your  console,
and you will see a lot of
information of the  performance
and number in different views of
different  devices and
application and versions.  There
are a lot,  one in particular
we will definitely and
exclamation  point.  And
generally, a lot means more than
5%.  So if  something is above
5%, there's something definitely
to  focus on and analyze about.
There are a lot of additional
statistics in this  particular.
Here you can see
, for example, you can see  how
the user is impacted and the
effect.
There is one questions.  We have
found out that  the matter
actually a lot, and they have
analyzed  applications on Google
Play and application rates,
again again, above five, they
have around 30% more one-day un
uninstallations.  So if you want
to avoid
-- even big  developers, like,
for example, Twitter here has
benefited from the statistics
and help them improve
experience for actually hundreds
of millions of users  all over
the globe.
Next chart is battery.  Our
Android team is  working
constantly on making some good
improvements to  increase the
battery life of each and every
device.  The  best way to keep
the battery alive is to
shut down most  of the features
and hardware that is not used
right now.   You as the
developer needs more power for
the  applications, keep the
device alive and behavior speech
can be difficult.
Wake lock.  You can definitely
keep the device  awake when you
need some processing power in
the  applications.  There is a
-- which is not that bad.  The
full lock is performed from
device, the screen is off  and
the user is usually actually
using the device, like,  playing
a game or driving the car with
the screen or  watching some
videos, and knows that he is
doing  something with the device
and probably wasting the
battery.  So it's not a a high
priority.  The priority  concern
is when the screen is off but
the application is  still doing
something in the background.
And sometimes,  this activity
can stuck and this wake lock can
work for  a long time,
sometimes more than an hour.
And when the  wake lock is stuck
for more than an hour, the
behavior  inside the application
actually Android Vitals.
Again, if you head to the
specific section of the
development console, you can see
a lot of statistics  where we
show you how many
stuck wake locks you've had  in
your application and the
particular Android version.
The goal here is to have a wake
lock.  It's optimal from  our
perspective.  And the wake lock
more than an hour,  then
something definitely going wrong
.
Why is this important?  We have
our own internal  study for
devices inside Google, and we
have found out  that in 30% of
cases when the users battery
charge and  lifetime value,
lifetime of the device, -- so
keep an  eye on them and try to
help users.
Other thing when you can wake up
the device in a  specific
period of time to perform some
type of  correction.  Again, if
you do this more often, it will
drain battery more, and we look
at the battery behavior
four or more wake-ups per hour
.  If you do it ten times  or
more, it's something definitely
to look after and  probably
increase the amount of wake-ups
in this case.
Again, the statistics that show
you which specific  API the wake
up and how many times per hour.
And the  worst-case scenario,
of course, is you have a wake-up
,  which then becomes stuck,
then it really means that the
battery will be drained.  So
this is the main point to  avoid
in terms of battery life.
And the last thing but probably
not the least is  rendering.
And as I said before, it's
generally fitting fitting.  We
are tracking two major points
here.   There's a slow rendering
and a slow rendering is when 50
50% of frames of the time
greater than 60 milliseconds
and a frozen frame when a
specific frame is 700
milliseconds or more.  And if
you have this, again, you  go in
the console, and you will be
able to see how fast  your UI is
rendered and.
In addition to the frozen flames
, we will also  note the slow UI
.  When the UI spread, which has
a lot  of for processing
activity goes, presume it should
increase the speed.  Again,
this is something to look  for
and probably move this activity.
So using
troubleshoot the app issues and
make it  more stable is one
thing particularly important now
to  measure the
app in the Play store.  But
there are other  components for
application quality, which are
equally  important, and I'm
going to talk about them in the
next  session.
So what's a quality app?  First
thing's first,  performance.  We
already model this discussion.
And  then there are features
that the users love.  There will
be beautiful design which fill
guidelines and the  application
should really focus on
supporting the latest  features
and technologies.  This will
create a wonderful  experience
for the users, and this will
make the users  love your
applications more.
First thing's first, the
material design.  We have  been
speaking about material design
for two or three  years already,
and in general, material design
gets a  lot of quality not only
from Google itself but from
independent designers all over
the world.  The materials  on
how to implement material design
and how to
applications according to our
guideline and you can  define
them.  Remember, that just using
some of the  preview components
, which are provided to you by
material design is not enough
fully compliant.  Design
property should design your
application from the ground  up
using things.  And having some
universal patterns the
applications Android platform
hearing familiar patterns  and
elements in the application
design really helps our  users
to be more engaged with the
application Android,  and it
really helps them to start using
applications  faster.
Next thing, next big thing is
platform support.   First of all
, quality app.  You should
always check your  application's
stability and performance
against the  latest professional
system, and you should
definitely  use the latest
available to build applications.
In  addition to that, a lot of
other Android platforms out
there and the more of them
support for your application.
Remember that there are plenty
of devices for  Android.  There
are wearables,
tablets, TVs.  Not all of  them
of course is for your
application use case.  The  more
considerable platform --
For example, smart TVs.  When
user is using your  application
not on a mobile device but on a
smart TV,  the user tends to
spend a lot of time before a big
screen and better engagement
for your entire application
application.
Wearables.  Wearables are mostly
, as in 75% of the  cases and if
the user is buying and using
wearables is  definitely more
engaged and focused because
already has  several devices,
which he uses frequently.  On
the  wearable means the
application will stay not only
on the  wearable device but on
the smartphone too, and the
users  will return your
applications each time they go.
VR.  There are a lot of
buzzwords against VR, and  there
are definitely a lot of use
cases right now.  Has  its own
specific platforms, for example,
definitely have  longer but
less frequent VR application.
There are a  lot of new ways to
interact with the users within
virtual reality environment.
Next thing is monetizeation, and
we are definitely  believe that
the user uses
your application for the
content.
So when you pass certain
thresholds in
premium
quality generating.  And
supporting of Android play for
scenarios in the context where
Android Pay is available  and
one of the first companies in
Europe which launched  in
support of Android Pay is also
great, and you should  focus on
new.
Next thing as to think about the
easiness for  users.
Like user create accounts or
sign into your  profile faster
and easier and focus on
communicating  with the users
who leave feedback.  Keep your
generating  above four.  So when
your application generating is
four  or more, it basically
opens each and every door for
featuring activities for a
collection inclusion.  So  this
is important and users on their
own language in the  reviews
sections will help you provide
great feedback  and communicate
with them.
The application itself some
tools in Google Play  and data.
First of all, there are a lot
of things
Google Play listing.  Then you
can use testing to see  what
works and what doesn't, and you
can better your  apps in the
channel.
A lot of things to work on and
when you start to  think about
your Appstore optimization, this
is your  number one destination
.  Title, icon, feature graphic,
videos and stuff like that,
they also, they all can be
presented to a particular
country.  Of course, those
wonders in terms of store.
And you see what works and what
doesn't, you can  use testing,
run experiments in a specific
language and  understand what
specific graphic screen or title
works  better for specific
users.
Why it's important?  Because
it's one of the best  things to
improve.  17% is not the top
number you can  get.  There are
some developers who get up to 30
% more  conversions of fully
optimizing Google Play.  And
remember successful experiment
have a clear hypothesis  of
testing, and you should have
some applications design  your
testing.  They shouldn't be very
similar or results  won't be
very --
And the last session of our
presentation is to  talk about
what you get from creating athe
best quality  app.  There are
main things and main benefits to
a  healthy app is search.  You
can get featured by our  Google
Play team, and you could get
recognized and  receive certain
awards from our colleagues.
So first thing's first is
visibility,  promotability, and
discoverability discoverability.
The better your  generating is
and the better your
video, the more  graphics from
the Google Play store.  Result
in  application engagement and
Android, they impart in,  first
of all, in the search.  So when
the user such as  applications
and having everything great in
terms of  applications will help
you boost your application to
the  top and get more traffic
and get more visible.  In
addition to this, there are a
lot of different  collections
inside Google Play store.  App
for work, app  for leisure, and
stuff like that.  And around 90%
of  those collections, they're
now automated.  So they are
graded by machine learning,
which picks up the  application
and group them for the similar
level theme  or similar.
And those collections more
usually have a better  quality.
High quality apps before
average quality apps  and
collections.  And, again, each
and every Google Play  user see
a different Google Play home
page, each time  they open the
Google Play store, and we try to
show them  the contents that
they might be more interested in
.  So  having apps and more meta
collections, and those
collections to the users more
for the use case.  And  this
will get not just regular
installation and not just
regular organic, but focused and
relevant graphic with  users
who are more likely
applications.
And next thing is you can get
featured and be  included in the
collections, which are curated
and  handpicked by our team,
Google Play business development
and merchandising.  Each app
is for featuring.  Goes  through
an extensive review from our
team and analyzes  the quality
and analyzes its design and
features and  provides them
feedback and provides them
requirements  for
improvement.  When those
requirements are met,  included
in some of our featured
collection, for example example,
new and updated collections.  A
lot of traffic  viewing.  Again
, quality is always a factor for
our  featuring requirements.
Now we have a lot of formal
requirements, for example, your
ratings should be more  than
four, you should have a good
generating in terms of  Android
Vitals, so getting your app
updated is number  one.
Before getting --
Again, featuring is usually
really important for  developers
and objects perspective.  So
you should get  featured and you
can feel appreciated.  But the
traffic  you can get from a
featuring is usually, the
traffic you  get organically
from applications over the
course of  several months or
several years of being
advertised in  search results
including automated collections
is  generally better, bigger,
and more than this one-time
featuring boost.  So working on
a quality for featuring  is
great because it gets you
visibility, but long-term
benefits of quality apps deliver
better results over  time.
And the last thing currently is
you can get  specific awards in
Google Play.  Currently, we have
two  types of awards and
recognitions
.  First of all, done by  our
colleagues in Google Play
merchandising, and
one app  gets buzz from social
media which is new and hot, it
can  get featured as an
application.  And there is
another
which we have launched just a
few months ago, which  requires
-- showcases best Android apps
on the platform,  which are the
best in terms of publication,
design  feature, relyiability,
and user feedback.  So getting
the  Android award is quite hard
in terms of effort and
what  you have to do.
But the applications, usually
the best Android  apps there are
.  And if you are looking
somewhere for  inspiration or if
you are looking for best
practices,  just head out to the
Android excellence portion of
the  Google Play store and check
it out because definitely
applications, you can check, you
can download, and you  can
probably reuse some of the -- in
your own  applications.
That's about all.  We'll have
some office hours  later today.
And if you have some additional
questions  about how featuring
how Google Play works, how to
get  featured, and how to
improve your application quality
,  please come in, and we can
discuss it.
Thank you.
[Applause]
for realtime captions...
test.
testing testing.  This is a
captioning test.  Please standby
for realtime captions.  The
panel
Please standby...
Nandini, and I enable
conversation between humans,
among businesses, and any
combination in between, some of
which include some machines.
series, developers? We just
launched this as a teaser on
YouTube, but it's coming and you
will hear all about that today.
But I want you to stop and
take a picture in your mind
right now of why voice is
wonder what you're thinking.
We're living in a time when
innovation is shifting our
outlook so rapidly of our
future.
It's worth taking a moment and
figure out how different it can
be in a week's time, a month's
time, and next year it will be a
different landscape than it is
here.
machines to speak on our
behalf, to speak to us out loud
is so deep to our context as a
culture and as human beings, it
makes us question where we are.
It makes us question where we
are with technology.  It really
is putting us at the
intersection of technology and
the human condition.  More than
ever before, we're actually
confronting a
have a lot more to say about
that, but today's not the forum
for that.  Today we're just
starting a conversation.  And
the hardest part about any
conversation is listening.  So
we want you to know, developers,
designers, businesses, we've
heard you.  We've seen the
feedback from I/O and
conferences like this is the
most valuable part of the
experience is interacting with
other Googlers and those
creating
to create a different feedback
loop for
helping you understand just how
to get your arms around this
interface, and how you
supplement that with other
elements like visuals.
have to work with, how to
create your landscape, how to
build your world for your users
in
So in the first season, we just
wrapped filming.  We have six
episodes.  We're going to have
things like greetings and
good-byes.  How do you start and
end a conversation.  How do you
identify users and authenticate
them.  And, how do you make
money at this? Transactions are
a big part.  We will show you
how to create custom voices to
brand your experiences.  What
does it take to create character
and persona? And also, what are
sounds involved
landscaping you can create in
all of this that's an entirely
new world that will create
gateways.  We will explore
deeper concepts and feature and
highlight examples from the
eco-system.  We want to showcase
what good looks
out there and what kind of
people it takes to make this
work.  And then on each episode,
we'll always feature guests
that will help us dig a little
deeper, and they will be people
from the community.
Sometimes they'll be Googlers
and a lot of
I'm going to dance.  So we're
going to do a little live show
today to talk a little bit about
what this means and hopefully
get a little bit of insight.
And we'll actually not answer
all your questions.  But we have
a few questions that I've
gathered from social media and
from our advocacy work that
we've done in that space.  To
start off, I want to introduce
our panel.  We have, first,
thrilled to have this great set
of panelists here that I
personally selected because I
feel like they're most
representative of where people
who have come at this and
pivoted to this field from other
areas to give us some insight
into their journey of how they
got here.  I think there are a
lot of experts in the field, but
very few that are considered
experts.  But there is just this
tapped in muscle that you don't
realize we have.  That's what
I'm hoping you can get out of
this today.  We'll start by
first we have Marc Paulina, who
together with Peter Hobson have
created a new methodology and
interactive design.  To give you
an idea on how we're really
taking the audience and building
with the audience and viewers
in mind, we built this panel
also directly from feedback from
you guys.  For example, Marc
just ran a sprint with peter
with a small group across the
street with this new
methodology, but it has to be
done in a small scale.  We want
to scale that big, so we're
going to show it on camera so
you can
Kimberly Harvey, who has
partnered
panel is a direct question from
the GDD community.
Research expert
asked for more representatives
from UX
And if you don't already know
him, Sachit has found the line
between design and engineering.
I credit him and his team for
pulling me out of my shell where
I was working and doing more
advocacy work.
example is the G plus
community, we reached out to
David Wang, who's going to be on
one of our very first episodes
talking about that from the
product
management team.  These are all
advocates for you, and we're
excited to get into some
questions.
so, Sachit, let's start with
you.  Voice.  What's all the
noise
for having me on the
an introduction, I'm an
engineer working mostly on
developer tooling.  I was
working on the living room team
before on Android TV and cast,
and Google Home became part of
the living room, and that's how
I got sucked into this.  About a
year ago, Nandini and I were
working on some of the first
samples.  If you ever have the
chance to help with app
rebuilding, she has an
extraordinary talent for the
get back to your question about
what's all this noise about? I
think that this noise that we're
hearing is the low, low hum of
the Sci-fi promise about voice
recognition.  We are at very,
very, very early stages of the
next motive interaction between
us and machines.  We've dreamt
about it for days and it's
finally happening.  But it's
still a little rough.  The
interactions are frustrating
sometimes.  But listen through
the noise for the signal of the
magical moments happening with
machines.  We will be talking
about these days years from now
when it's working as they
What's all the noise about?
what is exciting about it is I
feel like we're getting closer
and closer to a direct thought
download.  I studied
communication and cross cultural
communication
lot of different methods of
communicating.  Some may be
watching on video, using
gestures, words, systems of
writing are all around the
world.  I feel like having
humans interact in a way that's
been natural, because that's one
of the first skills that we
learn as babies can kind of get
rid of some of the challenges we
have, can get rid of some of
the challenges we have
Marc, you've been a designer for
a long time.  You started in
voice, actually way before we
had the Google Assistant.  What
an interesting time at the
moment.  Talking about the
journey that we've had, I wasn't
a voice designer before I
started working on voice actions
at Google.  I was working on
interactions in mobile,
automotive and TVs.  Voice, for
me, was quite a stunning
journey.  It was so different
than what I was used to.  For
me, it's been really
enlightening thinking about
voice and conversation and
natural user interfaces.  And
how there's such an emergence of
AI, internet of things,
robotics and so on.  So we've
got all of these natural usage
bases that set people's
expectations so much higher than
we've had before.  So, as a
designer, it's been exciting to
try and create the new design
methodologies where we can
understand people a lot more and
try to meet the expectations.
It should just work.  But right
now with the technology how it
is, there's a lot of really
interesting design
you know, that there is some
kind of forgiveness there.
People are at this point where
they're like, okay, we get that
it doesn't work perfectly all
the time.  And it's great to see
that people are working on
that, but, it's like, people get
the possibility, finally, which
is so exciting.  Let's start.
I have a few questions.  I kind
of pulled some from online and
others from asking around at the
conference.  We do
user-centered research, very not
last minute at all.  This one
comes from Twitter.  Is the
Google Assistant
Well, the first thing I would
ask, Bob, is why do you think it
is a Girl Scout? What lends
itself to that stereotype that
you
research.  But to answer the
question, I would say that the
Assistant is not a girl scout,
but it can facilitate
relationships like girl scouts.
itself with personality, makes
sure that the interactions we're
designing are on par with that
personality, make sure that the
wording is right, and shows
different parts of the
And the head of the doodle and
personality team has a great
analogy.  You ask personality
questions to poke at things and
ask it things that you can know
what to expect an answer
that.  It's a way of
establishing trust.  So when you
establish trust with your
neighbor, for example, you might
borrow a cup of sugar.  So
grant says borrow a cup of sugar
before you ask for the lawn
mower.  So how do you write
personality questions that are
just about the character that
you're interacting with as
opposed to the deeper
back-and-forth interaction about
whatever it is the task that
you want to
a great question.
zinger via LinkedIn, probably
for Sachit and maybe the others
the pipe in.  There's a common
sentiment among developers who
are leery about starting project
development in newer tools as
they have been burned in the
past by abandonment
the community-based nature of
design, can developers find
assurances that Google
recognizes this pillar and won't
be abandoning support for the
assistant SDK, or other related
projects? This is amazing.  To
allow innovators create new
products and found businesses
upon.  Well, I will say one
thing.  If we are doing that,
none of us have any jobs.  So
we're here.
from a developer perspective,
you guys work with tools and
APIs, so what would you
First, I would empathize with
the
It was Brandon Hunter from
LinkedIn who asked the
that before, and I certainly
wouldn't want to inflict that on
anyone else.  I would say on
this space that I think a little
bit extra of adventurous
attitude is actually called for
here from the developers' point
terms of picking up knowledge
around APIs and terminology and
figuring out what the design
looks like for these types of
things will pay off
exponentially in the future.  To
directly answer the question in
terms of Google's investment in
the space, I think it's clear
using the list of services and
APIs that the person asks the
question, it's very clear that
we're trying to push an entier
suite of products on developers
here.  It gives the idea that
Google is trying to push heavily
into the space.  Internally, we
are seeing this as sort of the
next step.  And this also is
shown through the consumer side.
Assistant has a company
initiative that reflects the
developer APIs and services that
we're releasing.
What's clear is if you look at
the scope of what Google is
actually putting out there that
we
see this as the next step for
users and developer s and we
will be supporting this going
forward.
platforms going away.  Clearly
the platform as a whole, the
conversational push as a whole
isn't going anywhere, and we're
sticking to
Thank you.  Okay.  Let's pivot
to design.  Marc, can you talk
about some of the design methods
you have used
So, as I said, learning the
design process, being new to the
field is quite a challenge.
that we used before for other
experiences, for example,
designing apps, websites, and so
on, for
learning new methodologies.  So
I, personally, take a lot from
service design theory.  One of
the principles of service
design is that we
democratize the design process
to come up with powerful
experiences and user-centered
designs.  The way to do that as
a designer or researcher or
anyone on the product team just
to be aware of who the user is
and what the user needs.  And
keep asking the question, what's
their goal? What are their
you understand about the user
the more interesting your design
will
entire expectations of the
natural user interfaces than
other types of interface.  And
also, best practices for
conversation design.  So one
principle we have over
conversation design is about
failure.  With technology the
way it currently is is there can
be a lot
language, there's a lot of
ambiguity.  We focus on this a
lot.  The happy
part is fairly straightforward,
but the unhappy part is quite
complex.  There's also
prototyping, so that's another
part is being able to validate
There's a reference in there
somewhere.  Happy little trees,
the Bob Ross method.  So we can
all talk, speak, gesture.  It's
the interface we learn first and
know best.  We don't need help
understanding that.  So why do
we need UX
UX research? Just because we
know how to speak doesn't mean
we know the intention of what's
going on.  Backstage, I was
saying let's say Marc was
outside in the center of the
hall, and I was talking to
someone and I said what does
Marc look like.  They would
describe him in a certain way,
he's wearing white shoes.  But
if Marc has been out for the flu
for the week and I turned to my
boss and asked what Marc
looked like, he would say he
looks a little better than last
completely different answer
based on context.  If we're
designing an experience, we
don't know until
we actually see it in motion,
whether we iron out all of the
kinks and whether there are
surprising behaviors that are
emerging
make sure you have everything
covered.
other disciplines as you get
into this, but just from a
developer perspective, getting
the ramp up into this, like what
can a developer bring into the
the great thing about our
platform in particular is it's
mostly driven through the cloud.
What that means is for
developers who have already been
developing in the cloud, web
apps or APIs they have been
building, they will bring all of
that experience in.  And the
tools they use to provide to
abstract some of the harder
problems like the natural
language understanding, those
tools are fairly easy to
understand for anybody.  So
first, learning that is fairly
simple.  There's a low barrier
to entry.  And with your
existing cloud web knowledge and
using basically efficient
coding practices around things
like string manipulation, those
kind of things, you can build
that pretty effectively on our
platform.  One of the things I'm
actually really looking forward
to, hopefully that I want to
see from the community is more
tooling and frameworks similar
to frameworks on other platforms
like web apps if you just want
to build a UI.  So I'm curious
to see how people will build
with reference to voice
you're early in the process,
you want to start prototyping.
So Marc, you have
suggestions on how to
I think about prototype,
looking at something that I can
use early in the design process
that I can learn quickly, and
it's really quickly.  So I think
it's really important that we
invest in prototyping,
especially if we don't have
years of experience working on
voice user interfaces, and that
we're really learning on
methodology that we've used
with some success designing
conversational UIs at Google,
such as Wizard Of Oz
prototyping.  The idea is you
remotely control the device that
the participant is using in a
study environment.  But they
think they're speaking to the
assistant, but
really they're speaking to me
as the puppet
what they believe is the
end-user experience, but there's
no AI or cloud, it's me on the
other
gets in terms of
can go anywhere.  You never
really know.  There's no set
path.  To feel natural, you need
to be able to pivot in
for that, the only person who
can do that is a real person
doing that in realtime.  Wizard
of Oz is powerful.  It can be as
simple as having a blue tooth
speaker, audio files that you're
playing as they respond.  It's
pretty good.
early on in the design process
is saying out loud, role
playing.  And Google design
sprints, where I've got the
whole product time designing the
conversations.  We actually do
investigative rehearsal, which
is a methodology created by Adam
Lawrence.  And it's basically
the idea is that you rehearse
the conversation in realtime,
and then you investigate that
conversation, and you ask
questions about it.
most scrappiest, most low
stability prototype you can
imagine, but incredibly powerful
for the first draft of the
conversation, before you invest
in any coded
mention that you, for those
sprints that you just talked
about, that you have the whole
product team there.  What you're
facilitating is a conversation,
to build a conversation, and it
creates better conversations in
terms of the actual
whole product team there.  It
democratizes the
user requirements, everyone
understands their goal and maybe
business goals as well.  And
everyone's thinking through that
at the same time and trying the
stuff out.  It really is a
platform approach
fact, that's probably a good
place to close and wrap up and
to get everyone thinking about,
you know -- I've been doing this
for a really, really long time.
So hopefully, if you feel like
we raised more questions in
this panel than answers, then
good.  Because there's a lot to
talk about.  As I said at the
beginning, this is just the
start of the conversation, there
are worldwide
one of them, and it's a much
larger one.  So a conversation
about the future of technology
and, you know, where we are
today and where we're going from
here is going to take a new
kind of eco-system.  This is
called a conversation
help, we need to build this new
eco-system.  We can actually,
at this point, take a quantum
leap past this AI first world.
Words really matter, right? It's
quite unfortunate that we call
it artificial at all when we
need things like authentic and
advanced intelligence more than
ever.  We are all starving to
amplify our own intelligence, so
maybe amplified intelligence.
#fixtheglitch.  It doesn't
matter, users come first.  If we
build a world using a
people-first creative approach
to building solutions that
people can use in their daily
lives, it's more than just
talking and getting answers
anymore.  People want insight,
and they actually want to be
able to do things in their
world.  We wand to find those
micromoments that are
there's another A-word.  We
just need the whole alphabet.
disciplines at the table.
Diverse voices, diverse
approaches, diverse thinking.
This is really a time when, you
know, it's like I sit at the
intersection of science and
culture, human interaction,
human solution to a global
problem.  Like, we built these
machines.  Let's make them work
on our behalf to make them
connect more to each other and
the world and the things we want
to get done.  I have been doing
this a long time, working with
this technology.  But really,
it's my personal mission to give
voice to others, and to help
create a culture that we can
create experiences that
illustrate a shared vision of
our future.  We need to
collectively recognize that good
means going beyond don't be
evil or do what's right, but to
create experiences to show how
it's done.  And so hopefully
with this series, you want to
show what that looks like.  You
want partner experiences to
showcase what you're creating
for your users.  And you know,
for the common good of users
everywhere.  So, you know, we
want to give insight to the
kinds of people inside Google
who are building this, and also
changing the lives and future
and technology, and also, you
know, this is the power of
spoken language.  What kinds of
people does it take to change
the landscape, you know? It's a
disruptive environment.  It's a
living our legacies in
realtime.  What are you going to
be known for? What kind of
world are you creating for your
kids?
We're going to create some
amazing things, and I can't wait
to see what you create.  Thank
you so much to our panel and
thank you to the audience for
being part of this exciting,
creative moment for us.  Thank
you.
>> Good afternoon, all, and for
those following  along on
YouTube at home, good morning,
good afternoon,  good evening.
I'm Brett Morgan, I work on the
developer  team for Google Maps
based in Sydney, Australia.
That  means I do things like
write sample apps, write
tutorials, Codelabs, and all of
that sort of things.  As  I said
, I look after Google Maps APIs.
Google Maps APIs  is the
oldest Google Maps service has.
Over ten years  old.  We have a
lot of APIs.  We have a lot of
interesting functionality that
you can use in your
applications.  One of the things
that we hear from  developers,
like yourself, is that that's
great.  You've  got all of these
APIs, you've got this wonderful
documentation, it tells you
what the arguments are, it
tells you what the result is.
But how do I as a  developer
take all of these APIs, glue
them together to  create
something that solves a problem?
So the JA  developers relation
team in Sydney came up with an
idea  of making solutions to
show
you end to end how to solve  a
problem.
So I just wanted to give you a
little bit of  history here.
Every year we have an annual
developer  conference, and a
couple of years ago, we decided
to  move it from downtown San
Francisco where it had been  for
quite a few years into Google's
backyard at
the  amphitheater.
Now, this was great.  Bigger
venue means we could  do bigger
things, have more people come
along.  But how  do you take
7,000 people from a bunch of
hotels all from  South Bay and
get them into this one event?
Well, there's a pretty easy
answer to that.  You  get people
in buses and move people around
with them.   But this is an
interesting opportunity for our
relations  team.
How can we best utilize Google
Maps APIs to show  people where
their buses are, and how long
it's going to  take them to get
between different points?
So Steve down in the front row
here and myself and  a bunch of
others put together a solution
that actually  did this.  Showed
attendees at Google IO the
realtime  location of their
buses and also showed them
timetables  of how long the bus
was going to take to get them
back  to their hotel.
So what we're going to do this
afternoon is walk  you through
that solution.  A quick little
note here  what we're building
is actually an asset tracker,
and  that one is specifically
called out in our terms.  So
before you go ahead and
implement an asset tracker,
please have a chat to our sales
about a premium plan,  because
you're going to need it.
Okay.  Let's have an overview of
the transport  tracker solution
.  So here's the architecture.
For  those of you who attended
the Flutter and Firebase talk
yesterday, this probably looks a
little bit familiar.   It turns
out Firebase encourages you to
actually  building this way.  It
does a very good job.
So what do we have here?  Well,
first part of the  problem is we
have 30 odd buses running
around South Bay South Bay, and
we want to know where they are.
So what  we did is we put an
Android phone on each bus with a
little suction cup holder to
keep the phone out of the  way
of the driver and a USB Power
Adapter.  And that had  a custom
application on it, which was
then turning  around and
publishing to Firebase the
location of the  bus.
Firebase is wonderful.  It turns
around and when  you push
information into it, it turns
around and  notifies anything
that's listening on that path.
So following on from that, we
have a Node.js  process running
in a Google compute engine
server in the  cloud actually
being notified that this bus has
moved  from here here to here
that process then cleans up that
data  and writes the cleaned up
location of the bus along with
timetable information, various
other things back into  Firebase
in a different location, which
then turns  around and changes
the display.
So at Google IO, we had big 60-
inch LCD monitors  that had --
as you saw previously -- the
realtime  information of the bus
and the timetable information.
So this is the overview
solution that I'm presenting
this information afternoon.
So let's dive in.  Let's start
with the first  component.
These are the Android phones.
How do we get  the accurate
location of the phone using
Android APIs?   Well, thanks to
Steve's code lab, which some of
you  probably had a go at
yesterday afternoon.  But if
you're  following on YouTube or
you didn't, I'll have links at
the end of the talk that
actually I'll link you to the
realtime code lab.
This, I just want to show you
the core component  that drives
the ability to track the
location.
So we're doing to start with is
configuring a  location request.
But
then reasonably aggressive here
,  we're asking for high
fidelity, high accuracy of the
phone, and we're asking you
every ten seconds.  This  means
the phone's going to be really
active.  The  circuit bug, the
radio circuitry is always going
to be  on, so this is going to
have battery implications, which
is why I mentioned before that
when we installed the  phones
in the buses, we connected them
up to USB phone  Chargers.  So
this is an explicit design
consideration  when I turn
around and do this sort of thing
, you need  to be aware of is
this phone permanently connected
to  power or not?
Another thing that we
implemented to deal with  this
was monitoring software.  So we
had the phones  actually writing
their battery level into
another part  of Firebase that
we had an admin user so that we
could  see all about the phone,
the current location, and most
importantly their power status.
Because occasionally, a  bus
driver would get into his bus
and go what's this  phone doing
here, unplug it, and we would go
and find  the bus and get them
to plug it back in.
Okay.  So we configured how
we're going to get  locations.
The next point is then use the
location  provider API.  This
gives us -- fuses together
cellular  tower data, GPS data,
Wi-Fi data to give us a more
accurate depiction of where this
phone actually is.
We then configure whereabouts in
Firebase we're  going to write
this location information.  But
finally,  we create a call back
to hand to the location provider
API that we can actually then
turn around and write the
results into Firebase.  And with
this ten lines of code,  we are
now tracking this in realtime.
Okay.  So we dealt with the
first component.  Now  we move
to the heart of the system.  The
Firebase  realtime database.
The Firebase realtime database
is a  very powerful realtime
communication tool.  For me,
while I was developing this
system, it was absolutely
insanely powerful because
traditionally when you're
developing a distributed system,
the main pain point you  have
is understanding what the whole
system is doing.   Now, because
I've got 30 phones wandering
around South  South Bay, I would
like to know where they are,
what  they're doing and in this
console, I can see which each
umph is doing at all times.
I can sit here and through this
console turn  around and make
changes to the data structures
and see  what the downstream
components do when faced with
certain edge cases.  This allows
you to effectively have
realtime development in a
distributed system.  You can
see what it's doing, change what
it's doing, all while  looking
at a nice Web browser-based
console.
Okay.  So told you about the
Android phones, they  put their
location information into
Firebase, Firebase  then
notifies our Node.js process
running on Google  compute
engine.  So this component has a
couple of  things that it does.
It has a list of
responsibilities,  but I'm going
to go through this.
The first one is while running
simulations, we  like to move
things around the map.  To do
that, we need  to generate the
paths the buses are going to
take.  They  start at a hotel,
go to another hotel, and then
wind up  at Google IO.  We need
to work out the path of all the
roads, the roundabouts that
that bus is going to take so
that the simulation looks real
istic.  The next thing I'm
going to show you is what the
server does with the phone
location to tidy up the GPS data
.  Tends to be a bit  noisy.
Okay.  So the first code snippet
.  Here's where  we're
generating a path.  Trip points
is where we're  going to take
all the points of the path and
take them  in and do things with
them later.  So this is
effective effectively just in
the could you tell me later
accumulateor.
For every stop, I have a
database of all the trips trips.
So what we're going to do is
get the stops that  this trip is
going to make out of that
database.  Here's  where we
create a directions API request.
At its  simplest, a directions
request has a starting point
and  ending point.  But in the
case we have multiple hotels
that this bus was going to, we
have way points, which is
between the origin and the
destination.
This is the line where we use
client library to  turn around
and make a request to the
directions API.  I  just want to
stop here for a second.  We
actually have  four client
libraries.  One, as you can see
here in  Node.js, one for Go,
one for Java, one for Python.
And  these client libraries take
the Web service APIs like we
have, like directions API, road
API, so on and so fourth  and
give you language-appropriate
help.  So for Java and  go, we
expose to you what the result
types are going to  be, so we
get -- if your browser or editor
gives you  type completion or
what sort of thing.
Okay.  Now that we've made that
request using the  power to turn
what's basically an
asynchronous operation  into
something that looks synchronous
, now we look at  the response.
Was it -- did it actually work?
And if  it did, now we
actually interrogate the
response  structure.  So a
directions response consists of
a set  of routes, and I'm just
going to take the first one here
because I don't really care --
well, I do care.  The  first
route is going to be the best
route; right?
For each route, we have a set of
legs.  This  traditionally
shows up as different models.
In each leg leg, there's a set
of steps.  And then finally in
each  step, we have a polyline.
So polyline is encoded format
for a list of lat longs,
location points.  So to code
this, I've got the points for
the step, and then I turn
around and glue them all
together, put them in trip
points, and then I use it later
for actually rendering  the
buses going around in simulation
.
So the second code snippet.
This is where I'm  going to deal
with the bus.  So the bus is
walking  around -- walking?
Driving.  Rolling around.  So we
have a bus moving around South
Bay, it's checking in  every
two seconds through Firebase
telling us where it  is.  So on
the server side, I collect a
history of the  location of the
bus.  A couple of minutes, in
this case,  and I take that
history, and I send it off to
our snap  to road API.  So this
is part of our roads to API
service.  So roads API knows
what all the roads are, and  I
can turn around and give it a
couple of minutes of  history of
the bus moving around.  And
roads API will  then take those
points, do some mathematics, and
make a  best guess as to which
road you're actually driving
down down.  So it effectively
eliminates the noise from the
GPS track.
So then we -- because we're
actually interested in  the
current location of the bus, we
take a list of  returned points
and take the very last one.
It's worth  noting here that if
you're plotting out a path to
something on a map, that you can
also ask roads API to  insert
additional points because as I
said, it knows  where
roundabouts are and curved roads
, so you can add  it additional
points to snapped road such that
when you  plot it, it's a nice
line that actually follows the
roads as opposed to just the
points that you sampled  using
locations provider.
In this case, we're not plotting
anything, so I  didn't do that.
I've just taken the most
recent point.
And of course there's error
recovery.
So now we're onto the final part
of the system.
This is where we put the buses
and a timetable on  the map.
So you might have seen the map
I showed you.   It doesn't look
like a standard Google map.
Well, what  does the coated look
like?  It looks like this.  We
have  a description language
that allows you to define the
set  of rules that tells our
mapping engine how to render a
map.  I don't know about you,
but I don't really want to  turn
around and figure out how a map
renderer is using  this.  I
would rather use a what you see
is what you get  wizard.  So
what I would like to show you
now is show  you how to use a
wizard to come up with a map
style.
Pray that the demo gods are
actually working.   Okay.  This
is our wizard.  I would like to
create a  style.  Sydney,
Australia
.  Can't tell where this was
written; right?
Let's go to Krakow.  Okay.  This
is the stock  standard Google
Maps styling.  But I'm creating
an  application, and I don't
want this style.  I want
something that speaks more to
Krakow.  Should we go with
something that's completely
saturated?  Or respecting
Krakow's history?  Should we go
with something retro?  I  think
I like this.  But it has a bunch
of visual noise  on it that's
not talking to me with the
application I'm  designing, so I
can then turn around and --
yeah, that's  better.  I've
calmed down the map.  Maybe I
want to take  off the landmarks.
Let's zoom in a bit.
How is that?   I'm happy with
that.  Okay.
If you want to dive in deeper
and actually make  more
modifications, we have a deeper
level here that you  can turn
around and play with the
individual settings  and see the
results in realtime.  But I'm
happy with  this map as it is.
So we give you two ways of using
this map that you just
configured.
The first one here is the JSON
language that I was  showing you
before.  This map styling
language is useful  in,
obviously, Google Maps for Web.
So using the  JavaScript API.
But it also works the exact same
language on Android and iOS.
So this way, you configure  your
map once and use it across all
of your applications
applications.
Question also give you static
maps, so if  you want to
configure it and style it in
some way, you  can do this, and
this saves you from having to
load a  JavaScript maps API.  A
much lighter response if you
know you don't want your users
interacting with the map.
Okay.  Now I've styled the map.
We're onto the  final part of
the journey where we've had the
information, start on the
Android phone, we cleaned it  up
in compute engine, now we're
going to display it on a  map.
we must be back in JavaScript
land, got a Firebase  database
we're taking reference on, now
we're listening  to a different
path in Firebase.  So this is
where the  compute engine hosted
Node.js process and writing the
cleaned up location of the
buses.
So what I've done here, I'm
writing an entry for  each bus.
So thus I can look up all the
buses all at  once.  I look at
each bus, and I have a routine
here for  what color marker to
put for that bus depending on
what  bus route that bus is
serviceing.
Then we create a marker.  Real
istically, you need  a bit more
complexity here to deal with re
using markers markers  because
if you kept creating new markers
, you would have  the screen
full of markers.  We move the
marker around,  and then you
delay it when the bus goes out
of service.
But I hear people out in the
audience screaming  the Web's
great, but I want to put it on
mobile as well.   How can we do
this?  Well, just so happens, we
have the  same code for Java.
We've got types here, we're back
in  Java land, we have a
database reference, we turn
around  and create a child
listener to add to the Firebase
to  notify us when things change
.  This time around, I'm  just
tracking a single bus, I'm not
turning around and  mapping all
of them.  I've got out of the
Firebase, I've  got the lat, so
that's the latitude of the bus,
longitude, and the bus route.
So now I have enough
information to turn around and
configure a marker on the  map.
Same logic applies here.  You
probably want to  hold onto the
marker once you create it and
move it  around.  Simple enough.
Okay.  So just to go over a high
level of what  we've just
covered, we started out in
Android using  location provider
to get the location of an asset
, we  published that location
every ten seconds into Firebase,
Firebase notified a Google
compute engine hosted Node.js
process to cleanup that data and
deal with the GPS  location
data.  That updated information
was written  back into Firebase,
which controlled a front-end
Google  map-hosted dashboard
that was shown to all the
attendees  at Google AI.  I've
also shown you how to do this
with  mobile.
So where next?
For starters, if you would like
to see the  documentation for
the Google map solutions that
we're  publishing, it's all up
on developers.Google.com.  If
you would like to have a look at
our client libraries  and our
open source code like the
samples -- sorry, like  the
solutions, it's all up on GitHub
.  And finally, the  code that
you saw in this talk is actually
lifted out of  three Codelabs.
The first code lab was the one
that  Steve and I hosted
yesterday, which was the asset
tracking code lab.  The code for
the Node.js process was  lifted
out of the transport tracker
back-end code lab.   And finally
, the code that I showed at the
very --  almost at the very end
of putting markers on a big
Google map was taken out of the
transport tracker map.   And
with that, I thank you for your
attention, and I  invite you to
give us feedback.  Thank you
very much.
[Applause]
>> My name is Thomas Steiner,
I'm based out of the  Hamburg,
Germany office.  And I work on
mostly Web stock stock.  And
with me today is my guest
speaker Steven.   Steven, want
to come up and introduce
yourself?
>> Hi, so I'm Steven. I'm
product manager at  Google in
California.  I'm just visiting,
guest speaking  today on the
identity on the mobile Web.
>> Thank you. So today, we want
to show you  what's next for
the Web or as an alternative
title,  exploring.  But before
we get started, here's a fair
warning.  There's a lot of
content coming, and I'm going
to speak fast.  Probably even
too fast, so hold onto  your
seats and especially watch out
for other links.  So  many of
the slides have links, and, of
course, you can  just snap a
photo of the slides so you can
look up some  of the content
after the presentation.
So let's get going.  Let's get
started.  Our first  big topic
area is proving Web apps or
short, PWA.  Let  me show you
how you can with PWA
create immerseive screen
experiences.  Because your apps
take up a lot of real  estate.
Some of you may remember iOS
2016, the paper paperplanes app
is still an app.
Pu launch this  application,
you might notice something.
This is a Web.   But if you
notice on the screen at the top,
there is no  network signal, no
clock, no battery status
notification notification.  It's
a true full screen experience.
And  you can do this by setting
the display property in your
Web app to the value of full
screen.
Very exciting for game
developers and, yeah,  hopefully
you can try it out for your
application.
For PWA, we also add to a home
screen experience.   Install the
PWA, they will not be able to
find PWAs in  the Android app
drawer, with just all the other
native  applications.  So they
look and behave and finally
react  as true native
applications, so you can just
search for  your app.  And
something that a lot of
developers have  really been
looking forward to, you can also
now update  the icon and change
the application name after the
application has been installed.
And something that's  really
cool as well is with the
improved flow, you can  now
based on the scope attribute
there Android in the  Web app
manifest, create an intent that
allows you to  react whenever
your pattern within the scope,
so your  application can just
open directly whenever it is.
And  I'm going to check, for
example, and go into the PWA
experience.
The next thing is the Web share
API.  Because we  all know that
sharing is caring.  And if you
want to do  that on pretty much
any site in 2017, you end up
with an  experience like the one
that you can see on the side.
So a lot of screen real estate
is in a sense wasted for  all of
these sharing buttons.  And, of
course, looking  at the sharing
buttons, always there's one
social  network that you would
actually want to share on is not
on the list.  And now as we
have seen on the slide with  a
full screen experience,
sometimes the URL bar is  hidden
, so you need a different way to
share your  application.  And
this brings me to the Web share
API.   It's integrated with the
native Android sharing dialogue
dialogue, which is really cool
because there, you have a  truly
native experiences --
experience of sharing your
content.  So if you look at this
code snippet, it's very  short.
Navigator.share.  You can give
a title, you can  give a Texas,
and you can give a URL, and
this allows  you
to change the URL that's
displaced on the screen.   So,
for example, something that is
hosted somewhere or  embedded in
the app cache, for example,.
The next topic is
Web notifications.  Directly in
the native system notification
pattern, so they no  longer
feel like strangers, they're now
just native  notifications.
Which also means they respect
your  devices or your systems do
not disturb setting, just
powerful because you don't want
to be disturbed by
notifications when you give a
presentation, for example,.
So the next topic is an
interesting topic.  Some
companies ship down three
megabytes of image data and
then ship it down on the site
and other companies have
worries about performance of the
service.
Navigation preload.  What this
does is it kind of  makes the
time or the service record boots
up not  waiting time but
parallel time that your app can
already  use for navigation
request.  So if you look at this
little diagram here at the
bottom of the slides, you can
see the service record boot time
before and the service  record
boot time after this trial is
activated.  So you  can see it's
running in parallel, so
the request can  already
happen.  If you look at this
code, you can see  there's two
events.  The activate event with
this  highlighted yellow line,
the wait, navigation preload
enable, you enable navigation
preload.  And then in your
fetch list now after going
through the chain of do I  have
the response.  Maybe no or yes.
You can check if  there's a
preloaded response that you can
then ship to  the users.  So
this allows you to get content
to the  user faster without
waiting time or the service
worker  to boot.
On mobile, you now have a pretty
exciting new way  of signing up
.  And this brings Steven on
stage.
>> Okay. Thanks, Thomas. So
what we'll talk  about here is
one part of the experience of
building a  mobile Web app that
is often frustrating.  It's only
a  small part, but it's often a
big part developers  encounter.
And that's how to get people
signed in and  signed up on a
small screen.  You've probably
all had  experiences like this
before where you have to
remember  user name, password,
type it in on a mobile keyboard
and  perhaps you've added
something like Facebook sign in
or  Google log in on your app.
But there's not people using  it
.  There's always a concern of
what information gets  shared
and how you end up back on the
site.  So what my  team has been
working on in Google is how to
improve the  mobile experience
for the mobile browsers out
there.   And what we're working
on out there is a new and un
unreleased API that adds an I
frame to your mobile site  where
you can offer one tap sign up
or sign in  experience.  This
gets someone into your site or
signed  up through
checkout or a conversion flow
with as little  friction as
possible.  And as a new thing,
we would love  to hear feedback
from developers like you on how
this  would work on your site.
So check out the link or send
me an e-mail.  Send us feedback
on this part of the  mobile app
experience.  Thank you.
>> So I'm going to use that.
Essentially, there's  two API
calls that you can make.  But
auto sign in you  can use smart
log.retrieve or smart log, you
can do  smart lock.hint.  You're
not spooned this code, it's
just to give you an idea of what
will be possible soon.   So
let's get back to PWAs in
general.  The question I  get a
lot when people develop a PWA A
and develop caches,  what am I
even allowed to use?  How much
storage do I  have?  Or if they
already have a cache full of
content  or somewhat full of
content, they're wondering how
much  of my cache am I using?
So with a new storage Web API,
you can now find out.  You just
very recently call  navigator.
storage.estimate, then you get
how much  storage you are
already using and how much
storage is  available in total.
A long time thing
by developers of PWA.  Let's
move on to the next topic area,
which is media-related  APIs.
Media on the Web is very
exciting and the next  thing I
want to talk about is image
capture API.   Because you
should be zooming in on what
matters.  So on  the screenshot,
you can see what matters is my
face.   I'm zooming in on my
face and the animation that I
created for the slide.  So this
API allows you to  actually
natively zoom in.  So this is
not large.  This  is native zoom
of the camera.  And you can use
this  directly from your
browser, and this is how you do
it.
So for this little demo here,
you can see the  slider and the
slider, that's of course how
much can it  slide?  So what is
the maximum zoom level?  And you
can  see this short snippet
code how from the media stream
you first get the track, check
its capabilities, and  from the
capabilities -- sorry from the
track, I check  the available
settings, and I can use that to
-- yeah,  update and create my
user interface to zoom in with
the  capabilities of the device
directly being used and being
applied.
So that's pretty cool, pretty
exciting.  Something  even
cooler and even more exciting is
the shape  detection API that
allows you to detect faces, read
bar  codes, and even to run
optimal character recognition
right in the browser.
I was just holding my phone and
pointing to  different browser
tabs where I had opened first a
QR  code and then on a second
tab, a face and some text here
here, you can see how in
realtime the guided
detects  different objects on
the page.  So this is directly
integrated in the browser.
So let me quickly show you how
it works.  You  first need to
initialize the different
detectors, so the  face detector
, the text detector, and the bar
code  detector.  And then you
can just listen for events.  So
everything you can cue up all
the different detectors  and so
on, and then you will get the
detected objects in  the results
.
So really cool, super easy to
use.  If you check  out this
demo, you will see its 100 lines
of code and  everything working
directly in the browser.  So
super  exciting, super cool API.
I think this unlocks a lot of
cool applications.
The next thing is the media
session API.  Many  play media
content on the Web.  You want to
know, of  course, well, what is
playing, when is it playing,
and  on a mobile device, you of
course want it controlled.   You
want to skip over, go to the
next track, pause, this  is all
possible now with the session
API.  You can see  meta
information of the currently-
playing media, and you  can, of
course, directly control it.
Let me show you as  well how
this works and what kind of
metadata you can  control.  So
in the screenshot here, you can
see there's  a title, there's an
artist, there's an album,
there's  artwork, and then you
have different action that you
have.
So a lot of things possible.
And this block of  code might
first look pretty intimidating,
but actually,  it's just too big
things and the first half are
sitting  here with the media.
And then on the second half, I'm
just connecting the action
handleers and connecting
functions with the different
events.  So super easy to  use.
Again, very powerful, great
integration
, to a  native operating system.
What we are.  Big topic.  Super
cool thing because  sometimes,
the real reality is actually not
real enough.   So what we are
allows you to create compelling
VR  experiences right in the
browser.  It's an open standard
that just allows you to
directly program these kinds of
experiences so that everyone
can get VR experiences very
easily.  You can see how this
could change the lives for
interior designers, for example,
who would just pass on  a link
to work that they've created to
their clients.   You don't have
animated 3D or anything.  They
can just  take out their VR
logos, cardboards, whatever and
then  take a look at how their
future home might look.  Super
cool directly in the browser.
Performance.  This is super
important, of course.   We
preach performance a lot.
Performance APIs no longer
allow you to have an excuse for
having a bad performing  site.
Network information API is
something that you can  use to
know how fast it can go.  Let me
show you what  you can do here.
So based on the connection
type of the  user, you can now
adopt your experience.  So, for
example, you can show someone
low resolution image  assets
when they are on a slow
connection.  And of  course on
mobile in a true mobile way, so
sometimes  you're in a tunnel,
sometimes you are on the country
side, and then sometimes you
are in the city.  So what I  am
getting at is connections change
.  So of course you  don't want
to have someone with a low
experience for the  entire
session.  But sometimes when
they have a good  connection,
you of course want to keep them.
So you can see how the code
reads out the  information but
then notifies when the
connection  changes.  Why is
this important?  Well, you of
course  have media queries.  So
you can say, well, this user is
on a retina display super high
resolution Apple book but
actually combined with that
information, it might after  all
not make sense to show them
super high resolution  images.
So this is just a short example
of how you can  programmatically
from JavaScript check for the
results,  then combine it with
the connection API to see if the
connection actually right now
is good enough for  supporting
high res images.  So you can
directly work  with media
queries and with the connection
API together.
And there's the core performance
API because you  do care or
should be caring what's
happening when a page  loads.
For this, I was very quickly
auditing the actual  event page
for the GP.  So there's a lot of
different  things that you can
get and calculate and an take
the.   So I can see here I'm
getting the data from the window
. window.performance.timing
object, and then you can
calculate a number of things.
Like, for example, the  page
load time or the connect time or
the render time,  and these are
core metrics that it could then
just  simply report back to
your analytics back-end, and you
can see how the real users in
the real world out there
experience my page.  And you
then see alarming numbers,  it's
probably a good idea to get
going and improve your  site and
get it to load faster or render
faster.  So  that's really cool
.
But then, this is only one part
of the story.   Something more
interesting and more important,
actually,  is making sure that
content in a meaningful way gets
to  the user.  So what it can
do now is with a timing API,
information about key painting
events.  So when did what
content arrive at the user's
device?  And there's even a
performance observer, so I can
get that notified and  react
whenever a certain page happens.
I was operating this page on a
slow 3G connection,  and you can
see here on the console it's
relatively  small I think, but
you can still maybe see it, the
first  kind.  So when was the
first moment something no matter
what was painted and when was
the first moment where
something meaningful was painted
?  So, for example, text text,
for example, an image so that
people can actually  consume
content, not just stair at a
gray background or  a white
background.
So for super easy for API, of
course core metrics,  these are
core metrics that can, again,
record back to  analytics and
see if everything is okay.
Client hints.  Also very
exciting topic.  That  allows
you to adopt and see what kind
of device you have  to do with.
We have in Chrome telemetry, so
we have a  feeling of what's
going on with the browser, and
we've  noticed that a lot of
foreground crashes are actually
due to out of memory exceptions
.  So when the device  runs out
of memory, the Chrome tab might
crash.  So you  can see here an
Android phone more on the
cheapened of  the spectrum.  For
these kinds of devices, it
might be a  good idea to not
serve super, super high res,
super RAM- RAM-heavy experiences
, but maybe adopt it.  So, first
of  all, servers can advertise
that they support.  For this
there's a new code accept-CH,.
CH for client hint.  And  then
it can provide different line
hints that it  supports, for
instance, device memory.  And
then it can  send the device
memory, for example, I'm a poor
ish  device, I have .5 gigs of
RAM only, so then the server
can adapt the experience
accordingly.  And also, you can
read
out this information on the
client side with  JavaScript.
So you can just have a look at
navigator. navigator.device
memory and see what is the
actual  hardware device memory
right now.  And you can also see
how many corresponds does the
CPU have?  So when you  program
a game, for example, you can
decide to use heavy
architectures or
textures or the heavy textures
?  And also, how many
corresponds does the CPU have?
Super exciting; right?  New
features.  Which then  brings us
to hardware-related APIs.  The
first API that  I want to
mention is the Web Bluetooth API
, which allows  you to
communicate with nearby
Bluetooth devices.  In  this
demo here, you can see how with
his phone, he's  controlling
Bluetooth canals.  I wasn't sure
that this  kind of thing exists
, but it does exist.  Bluetooth
canals.  You can see why this
would be fun.  You can  just
allow anyone with a device that
is in range to  control the
experience here.
Using the app, so generic
profile, and uses  Bluetooth
core.  So very energy efficient.
Implemented  in Android, Linux
, iOS, and in Chrome wear.  Very
exciting API.
The next thing is Web USB.
Which allows you, as  the name
suggests, to expose USB devices
directly to  websites.  This is
of course not for any and all US
B  devices but for USB devices
that are specifically  designed
for that.  And this demo here
created by
Kenneth Rhodes, you can see
how he is using an Arduino
board to display text on a
screen.
So these devices need to be
specifically designed  for being
used on the Web, and it's
obviously HTTPS only only, so
this is a very powerful API, so
you want to be  sure that this
is HTTPS only and, of course, it
has to  be initiated, so you
can't just secretly connect to a
US USB device.  It's always
after user suggestion.
Again, implemented on Chrome,
Android, and  Chromecast.
Today, there's one more thing.
Today we're  launching Web SCSI,
which allows you to have your
old SC SCSI hard disk and bring
the '80s back to the Web.  SCSI
is a small computer system
interface for transferring  data
between devices.
Has a controller right in the
browser and defines  interface
for access.  It is landed in
Chrome 64 preview preview.  Very
excited about that.  This was,
of course,  a joke.  But what I
was getting at is this is not
the  end.  This is just the
beginning.  The Web is so great.
The Web is ever evolving.
And if you want to stay up to
date, we very much invite you to
subscribe to developers
developers.Google.com/Web/
updates for all the great, new
things that are coming.  With
that, thank you.
[Applause]
>> Hi, everyone,. Thank you so
much for coming.   My name is Je
n Person.  I'm a developer at
Google for  the Firebase team,
and I am so thrilled for you to
be  part of this, my first talk
as a Googleer.
[Applause]
Thank you.  Thank you so much.
Yeah,.  I really  can't think of
a better place to do it.  I
hope you had  as much fun as I
have.  I've seen some really
great  talks and some really
awesome training.  And met some
of  you, and I hope to meet more
of you, so thanks so much  for
being here.  So what I want to
talk to you about  today is
incorporating Firebase into your
existing app,  so what I found
is talking to other developers
at  conferences, you know, you
may like the idea of
incorporating the Firebase
database or storage or
authentication, but a lot of
developers already have an
existing app that has all of
those things in it, so they
think Firebase isn't for them.
But I'm here to tell you  that
there are some features that are
still very useful  for
incorporating your app,
especially to grow your user
base.
So I'm going to talk about two
main topics.  One  is app
quality and another is app
growth.  I find when  designing
what to talk about, these things
really went  hand and hand to
me because a lot of what makes
an app  grow has to include a
quality app.  People aren't
going  to be sharing the app
with friends and telling them
about it if it's crashing.  So
I'll briefly spend a  little bit
of time talking about the
Firebase features  that can help
with your app's performance and
your app  quality, and then
I'll talk about some of our app
growth  options.
So according to a study of one
in two star reviews reviews,
nearly half of the complaints
are related to  prompts
developers can address.  So
crashes and  performance.
Exactly what I was talking about
.  And  since we all tend to
want to be informed consumers,
we  tend to look at our reviews
first.  I don't know about  you,
but I have not bought anything
for the past, let's  say, five
years without looking at the
reviews first.   So definitely
poor reviews can curve your app
's growth.   So with that in
mind, let's take a look at the
app I'm  going to use as a
sample to incorporate Firebase.
And  it's called friendly
translate.  And if you've done
any  of our code so far, you
know that I love things that's
friendly.  It uses the cloud API
to translate from a  couple of
different languages, and it
doesn't use  Firebase.  At least
, not yet.
So I'm going to show you
friendly translate.  And  here
it is.  So simple interface.
Looks a little bit  like another
translate app that you may know
.  Has some  languages to choose
from, and it
-- I am glad you are  here.
Now you can see how bad I am at
texting on a  small screen.
But, yeah, that's all there is
to my app.  Back to  the slide.
Okay.
So even though I have a totally
awesome translate  app, it is
certainly possible it can have
some not so  great reviews.  So
what do I do if I'm getting
reviews  like these in the
Appstore or the Google Play
store?   These really aren't un
like reviews you have seen for
other apps before.  I even did a
very quick search of  the
Appstore and found one that
could actually pertain  to
something like this.  Reading
other reviews, I  realize that
it's not just me.  It has been
at least a  month or so since I
tried using the app on my iPad,
but I couldn't because it
crashed for me instantly.   That
was a while ago.  Again,
definitely something you  would
not want potential users to be
reading.
So sometimes reviews will tell
you exactly what's  going on.
But you may not know why users
dislike your  app.  So Firebase
has a bunch of features to help.
I'm  going to take a look at
each one of those reviews I just
showed you, and then show you
how a Firebase feature can  help
you address that issue and thus
, help you grow your  user base.
Let's look at this one.  Always
crashing.  We see  these ones a
lot, and they can have a huge
effect on how  your app is
received.  And so even though I
know what  the problem is, this
doesn't really help narrow it
down.   If I had some crash that
I didn't have in my initial
testing, it can be tough to do
so if I haven't already  found
it.  So
Firebase for a couple of
different  resources for
reporting and finding crashes
happening in  your app.
Firebase crash reporting has
been around for  a while and
Firebase developers like it.
And I imagine  that you heard
that Google recently acquired
fabric,  which provides crash
analytics, which is another
report  for crash reporting.
In fact, if you go to the
Firebase console right  now, and
you haven't registered any
crashes yet, this is  the screen
you'll see.  And it's pretty
clear from  what's written that
Firebase is using crashlytics if
you  haven't already.  It's
even a slightly different color.
But there are still reasons you
may want to use  one or the
other.  No matter which option
you choose,  just know that
Firebase will help developers
migrate  easily to a final
solution that combines the best
of  both of these.  If you're
developing an Android app, in
fact, you could just incorporate
both.  On iOS, you do  have to
choose.
So while there are good reasons
for both of them,  I wanted to
try out
crashlytics.
It can help you and find resolve
problems quickly.   And it can
minimize the crashes for your
users by  focusing on the ones
that are impacting most of them.
And it's available on iOS and
Android.
Now, Firebase -- other pardon me
.
It will give me  deep insights
into what's crashing in my app,
and it  will send me
notifications.  Here you can see
there's  been a crash in
friendly translate.  So let's
take a  look at just how fast it
reports on crashes.  I happen
to know there is a crash in my
app, and I'm going to  make it
crash for you right now.  I'll
take a look at  crashlytics
shortly after.
So here I have my app.  After a
moment, we'll be  able to see
that in the console if you want
to pull up  the computer.  Thank
you.
And we have our crash reported.
So it really is  that fast.
You can really find out what's
going on in  your app in
realtime.  And because it
aggregates this  different
crashes, you can see what this
trends are.
Now, what about a review like
this one?  The app  worked
quickly for me on my new device
and my fast  office Wi-Fi.  This
is something that you may have
heard  before.  But depending on
where your users are located
or what kind of devices they're
using, they may not have  that
same experience.  And certainly,
try to test in  several
different scenarios, but you
will not  necessarily patch very
specific issues that way.
So I can monitor and address
performance issues  using
Firebase performance monitoring,
and it gives you  actual
insights into your app's
performance from a user user's
point of view.  And it was
released in beta at IO  this
year.
Performance monitoring can tell
us how the app  performs from
your user's perspective, and it
runs in  the production version
of your app with minimal over
head overhead.  So you can rest
assured that it's not bogging
down your app in the process of
trying to improve it.
So performance monitoring offers
a couple of  features right out
of the box.  Automatic tracing,
and  you can create custom
traces.  And also, automatic
HTTP  and HTTPS metrics.
So a trace is a report for a
period of time that  is going to
have a defined beginning and
end.  And there  are some that
are done automatically like a
cold app  start, how long your
app is in the foreground, and
how  long it's in the background
.
HTTP and HTTPS traffic metrics
include response  time, which is
going to be from the moment of
indication  to the final fight
that's received.  Payload size
and  bytes, and success rate.
So it's going to take a look  at
your status codes like 200
types being successful and  500
type errors, and it's going to
help you narrow down  if there's
a specific server or network
issue that's  causing that.  It
also includes URL pattern glot
ting.   So, again, you're
aggregating the different URLs
so that  all of these will be
considered the same structure so
that it gives you an
aggregated view of how your APIs
are performing.
And the transaction metrics it
includes are app  version,
device, OS level, carrier, and
radio, which  I'll show you what
that looks like in the console
.
Now, this is a sample of an app
that is live and  uses Firebase
performance monitoring.  What I
want to  briefly show you,
besides the traces, including
the  defaults and the custom
traces is that deep insight you
can get is network request.  So
here, if I want to find  out
more about what kind of response
time I'm getting, I  can have
it, again, broken down by how
long each carrier  is taking,
and the app version, and what
device it's on.   Really narrow
it down if I'm having some issue
,  sometimes it can be just a
single carrier that's causing
it, and this really helps you
narrow it down.
All right.  Thank you.
Okay.  So sometimes your
feedback is not  particularly
helpful.  And not to mention
that very few  of your users are
going to be giving that
feedback.   They're not
reporting the issues, they're
just unin uninstalling the app.
So how do we find out what
users  like and don't like about
your app?  That's where Google
Analytics comes in.  And what I
love about Firebase,  it's un
limited.  So you have this
option when you  incorporate
Firebase into your app that
gives you  reporting on up to
500 distinct events, and you can
have  custom events with custom
parameters, and you can view
all of that data, including how
it connects up to other
Firebase features, for instance,
if you use crash  reporting,
you can incorporate that into
your analytics.   Take a look at
your dynamic performance,
notification,  in app purchase
data, and see how your campaigns
are  performing.
Oh,.  Right.  Next feature I
want to talk about is  remote
config.  This is another way
that -- this is  another feature
that works well with analytics,
really  narrows down what
people like about your app, what
they  don't like about it, and
helps you give a custom
experience to your users.  So
remote config lets you  change
the behavior and appearance of
your app without  pushing an
update.  So you don't have to
depend on your  users to do so.
So if you're anything like me,
there's  at least 12 updates
that need to be done.
Especially if  you have
something important lake a crash
that you want  to resolve by
removing the feature, you don't
want to  have to wait for them
to them to update it.  You can
use  the Firebase console to
override default values, so you
can have default values for
different scenarios,  including
user properties.  App versions,
operating  systems, audiences
that you define in Firebase
analytics analytics, it's really
up to you how you want custom
that configuration.
your app's color  theme to
match a seasonal promotion or
for a sale.  Or I  can use
remote config to change what the
default  language is going to
be.  On one hand it's possible
that  in a certain country, they
may want to start with
whatever language is native to
that area.  Or maybe a  lot of
people using the app in that
area are visiting,  and they
want to translate something into
that language.   So depending
on where somebody lives, you may
want to  have a different
default language.
So here I can use remote config
to change what the  default
language is and use the region
where the device  is located to
decide which language is shown
as being  the original one.  And
I can show you that here.
Bring  up the phone?
Is it possible to bring up the
phone?
I'll just  hold it real high,
so you can see.  Well, come up
and  check it out later because
I'm pretty excited about that
one, and I'll show it to you.
Okay.  So according to a study
by local analytics,  23% of
users abandoned an app after
just one use.  So  those few
first moments that a user
interacts with an  app are
critical.  You don't want to
become part of  those statistics
.  So Firebase provides some
great tools  to make the
experience as easy and as
enjoyable as  possible.  And the
ones I wanted to talk to you
about in  a little bit are app
invites and dynamic links.  Also
,  to go with app insights and
dynamic links, 82% of  Americans
asked for recommendations from
friends and  family.  And that's
even higher at 92% for 18 to 24
24-year-olds, which is why
these features are so  powerful.
So app invites allow you to
share referral codes  or content
via SMS or e-mail.  And it
really is an out  of the box
solution that enables you to
send invites  from your actual
users to their friends.  And who
can  give better
recommendations than people who
already  enjoy your app?  And
with a few lines of code, you
can  send out those invites.
And this can include dynamic
links.  So rather  than just
going to let's say the default
page in your  app, if there's
some specific contents that that
user  would be most interested
in, you can have a link that
sends them there and even
survives the install process.
So let's say you've fixed your
performance issues,  you solved
your crashes, and you have made
it a much  better experience.
How do you reengage those users
that  haven't touched your app
in a while?  Firebase cloud
messaging makes it super easy.
So Google Cloud messaging sends
out so many  messages every day,
and they are nearly instant and
very  reliable.  Firebase cloud
messaging -- let me
--  Firebase cloud messaging
makes it really easy to send
out messages that are directed
to specific groups,  rather than
just spamming messages to all
of your users.   Oh,.  Yeah,.
[Applause]
So let's say that this
particular user in this  case,
me, is not very interested in
using the app  anymore because
every time I try to pick my
favorite  language, it crashes.
But now that crash has been
resolved, I can send a message
to a specific group.  It  can be
based on properties or events,
and I can just say
back to translate.
Because we can switch back and
forth  too fast, you may not
even see the notification
because  it can come through
very quickly.
And there we are.  Come back to
friendly translate translate.
Invites me to come back, and it
doesn't have  to be a simple
message like that it can include
links  that you want them to be
in your app.  This is a simple
example.
So, again, you can use Firebase
cloud messaging to  invite users
to drive user engagement and
invite them  back to use your
app.  You can send messages all
the way  down to a single device
, groups of devices, have topics
that they're subscribed to.
There are endless  possibilities
to reengage your users and,
again, without  spamming them by
making it simple for you to
choose  specifically who that
notification pertains to.
There we go.  And there's one
last thing I wanted  to show you
that incorporates analytics
using Cloud  Functions for
Firebase.  Because I'm a huge
fan of Cloud  Functions for
Firebase.  If any of you have
seen my  video, you know I love
to talk about them.  So I
couldn't help but include an
example.  So I wanted to
briefly show you some code
with how you can incorporate
analytics events to reengage
users with your app.
So what I've done here is create
an event that is  triggered
when the app is removed.  And,
again, this  occurs in the
server side and not in your user
's app.   So in order to have
this event trigger, just make
sure  that if you're using
analytics events trigger for
Cloud  Functions for Firebase,
it has to be conversion event.
So you may have to go to the
console and make sure it's
triggered as a conversion event.
So if an Android user  removes
the app, you can log that event
-- or it is  logged
automatically, and you can send
them an e-mail,  and you can
invite them back to use your app
.
Now, in this case, I wrote out
verbatim.  I wrote  out
specifically for each language.
You could even  incorporate the
translate API here as well if
you wanted  to make sure that
you're translating to whatever
location the user is at, what
language they would be  using.
But in this case, I figured it
may make sense to  hard code
something because if some sort
of faulty  translation is the
reason that they stop using your
app,  you wouldn't want to
incorporate here as well.  You
would want to make sure that
everything was translated  in a
way that looked right to them.
In this case, I  don't speak all
of these languages, so they may
not  actually be the best
translations.
So, again, using the -- sending
them an e-mail,  logging the
event, and that way any time a
user decides  to leave my app, I
can invite them back, and I
could  even give them some sort
of discount or motivation to
come back.
And the slides again, please,.
All right.  So after making some
great changes to  my app, seems
like people like a lot more now
.  Five  stars with translate
again, and it translates so fast
and so easy to use and fun.
So these are all features  that
you can incorporate into your
app, even if it's  already up
and running, and that's actually
the best  time to use them, to
really get your idea out there.
I  mean, you've already spent
the time to build something  and
come up with a great idea.  Why
not really make sure  that the
users who would enjoy it are
actually getting  to see it?
So here's a summary of the
features that I added.
Crashlytics, performance
monitoring, remote config,
Firebase cloud messaging, app
invites with dynamic links
links, and because I can't help
myself but talk about  Cloud
Functions, I also added a brief
example for using  Cloud
Functions with Firebase with
node Mailer to send  out a
message whenever a user removes
an app from their  phone.
So thank you, all, so much for
coming.  And I hope  you're
having a great time here at GDD
Europe, and I  hope to see you
next year.  I'm Jen Person.  If
anyone  else has any questions